this morning we remember captain sir tom
moore
who became a hero in his 100th year on
earth
london's newspapers are leading the
tribute to the world war ii veteran
known simply as captain tom
he died yesterday less than a year after
he caught the public's attention
and affection by walking around his yard
to raise money to fight the coronavirus
charlie dagda
has more taken away by the very virus he
rallied the nation
and the world against captain sir thomas
moore had no idea in those first few
steps in his backyard
he was stepping onto the world stage the
world war ii veteran aimed at
a hundred laps for his 100th birthday
maybe raise a thousand pounds roughly
twelve hundred dollars
for embattled workers of britain's
national health service
going global change that captain tom
became a household name
he ended up raising more than 45 million
dollars
what did that money mean for the men and
women of the nhs
those funds have gone through the length
and breadth of the uk
it's gone to every single nhs charity in
the country
he got a spitfire fly pass for his
birthday and personal messages from pop
stars to royalty
you see you get 125 000 birthday cards
this year
how many did you get last year do you
remember
[Laughter]
he was awarded an honorary promotion to
colonel
then the notion of knighthood how do you
like the sound of sir tom
it was rather nice to be called sir
thomas more but
it isn't going to happen well it did
happen
the queen made a rare self-quarantined
exception to make captain tom
a knight of the realm captain tom's
motto
became the title of his book tomorrow
will be a good day
but for many tomorrow will be a sad day
in a world without
captain sir thomas more in it
tomorrow will be a good day he said it
to me every time that we've spoken it's
who he was he was full of
warmth and kindness and optimism he was
a ray of light through the darkest of
times
anthony charlie dagetta in bedford
england what a lovely man and what a
last act charlie thank you